right good evening everyone um and
welcome and particular welcome to Da
sparing it's his first executive meeting
so well done and congratulations you
think that there you are or
considerations which way you want to
look at it uh right emergency evacuation
please note this meeting will be audio
recorded uh should we required to
evacuate the building would you please
leave the room by the door to the fire
escape stair case please hold both
handrails in case the stairs are wet or
slippery if anyone is unable to use the
stairs they please allow others to exit
the room before they go to the fire es
gate door where they can G then be given
assistance our assembly point will be in
the public car park at the side of the
Civic Suite please do not delay your
evacuation to collect any belongings and
please do not return to the building
until given permission to do so by
Council staff uh right apologies for
absence I've got apologies for me and
Ward georgeu who's feeling a lot better
apparently uh and from Jun Lely um I
don't think there are any others uh no
nor members attending
um so minutes of the meeting held on the
6th of April is it your wish that i'
sign them as a true record thank you uh
any Declarations of interest if anything
arises during the meeting please declare
it then and we'll make sure they're
anotated um item five man M has referred
to the executive and reports from other
committees um don't believe there are
any so next one is progress on decisions
and just go to the
schedule right start up page one and
please cut in or if you backrack a
little please do at any time uh right
Devolution uh I think members are aware
of the position at the moment um we're
not going for the meral uh option at the
moment but let's see how that uh
responds I understand the letter is
going out to the government and we'll
see what the response is on that um
anything else on
6.1 all right 6.2 I think they're all
finished with as is 6.3 and 6.4 I say
please do come back if there's anything
you wish to talk through 6.5
6.6
6.7 uh
6.8 okay 6.9 yes please
pleas you go are you far away I don't
want to step on your toes no no you go
right
um three um I I I agree with what's said
there I think it's just the way that
it's said that uh need needs a tiny
little bit of attention
um it talks about Market testing be be
undertaken of the facilities in
homebridge and and ra together with
adjacent land to ascertain whether there
is business potential in developing the
sites for alternative uses um on the
basis of an obligation to keep the
facilities open to the public I think we
absolutely need to be clear there that
um we're talking about toilets rather
than facilties
and that we're talking about keeping
them
open I think there's a tiny bit of
ambiguity and if if I were looking to uh
misinterpret it uh I think there is some
possibilities so I think we just need to
ensure that the word toilet is in there
and the word
open is there for the to to make it
absolutely crystal clear please okay
yeah ter yeah there was an email in I
guess most of you have seen it from uh
Christine Mason this evening questioning
some of the figures that were reported
I'm not see came in came in this evening
um well it was dressed to
Marcus um let me try and find it I
can going this
one there we go um
it was addressed to Marcus copy copy to
me John Mason Michael Hoy Toby mounting
dear Marcus I refer my previous
Communications regarding the surveys of
the public toilets and the inaccuracies
of summaries given to the executive I
had anticipated this would be corrected
however I note that the information
provided for tonight is still inaccurate
based on the surveys that you provided
would you please ensure that this is
corrected before decisions are made
based on Flor flaw
reporting so I obviously I have
little background as to what has
generated this
um but you know in in in light
of some of the com the comments made I I
I don't assume that there is any move at
the foot at the moment to to close any
of the toilets that have been
highlighted
what we've talked about this is ongoing
yeah
exactly um and as I say it's I think the
the notes say or you know overhaul our
approach seeking to include wi Community
Options for the provision of public
toilet you know that we're still
exploring how we can take that forward
and how we can do it in a way that
actually covers more of the costs and
actually provides hopefully better
facilities for the public as well um and
and uh you know the sort of hours that
they need them so I think that's that's
we want to proceed but I know that when
we looked at the figures that came
through last time um some of the Figures
were I think were clearly flawed weren't
they CU we questioned them last time so
I think we're aware of the fact and I
know that Mark is supposed to be coming
back with further figures or at least
modifying the figures that he' had
because they didn't read right uh so you
know I think that's an ongoing thing and
I think this this uh it says further
reports to the executive on various
options have been explored um I think we
need to emphasize there that uh we need
proper figures to be able to work on
them as well so how do you want me to
answer this this one well uh I'll come
back to you for that I yeah yeah okay
but it's there so you know it needs uh
needs responding
to okay yeah chairman there will be a
note in the uh in the minutes in
relation to what's just been uh been
indicated in the event so that'll
probably okay thank you right any more
on 6.9
please
610 it's carrying on so 611 R functions
hopefully we can get that going put that
somewhere here ter if I may just get
back to 6 Yeah by
tomorrow I think that really should be a
red now because that's been going for so
long yeah um Can somebody elaborate
where we stand with this
scenario
um are they operational do we use them
how we how do we go about contacting
them are they at our disposal now
or where do we stand with these well I
understand they're still employed by um
the highway Authority through uh what's
the company uh J Jacob
uhing um and uh the talk is you know
about the argument was about whether
they Chey over it wasn't it or whether
you know we just take the the cost if
you like of those stuff and I think
there was
a there was a a disparity between them
showing that they actually work the
number of hours they needed to in order
to trigger the TP Arrangements I think
that was the thing and that's that's the
conversation that's going on at the
moment I think that that's correct I
mean I think the the from From
rushford's perspective the notion was
that the County would uh give Rochford a
sum of money and Rochford would make the
arrangements to do the sorts of work
that the Rangers had been doing uh
through our own contractors H however as
you say the argument was was was raised
that there was concern about whether the
staff that currently uh uh act as
Rangers uh would have to be 2 ft across
and I think that's where the debate has
founded um because from Rocher's
perspective we don't want staff toh to
come across in in that in that in that
way so that's why uh the debate has
dragged on for so long the ranges I
understand are still operational in fact
because uh you know I know there's been
some dialogue recently about uh uh um
various works that um I think one or two
parach have asked to to be carried out
so uh but they're definitely still
operational um under living Jacob's
umbrella which officer should they
report through
normally
it was yourself at one time but I don't
know who Marcus who's been who's been
looking at this uh this issue of of how
the uh how the responsibility transfers
to Rochford so that we can actually uh
actually undertake the Undertake the the
works on behalf of the the residents but
you know as I say The Stumbling bulk has
been the uh the Rangers themselves and
whether they would have to be too
bigr so that's where we sit at the
moment so really in limbo land with this
along with most the other bits and
pieces final drive report of the
agreement is being prepared by ACCC so
there's not a time scale on here
assuming that's going to come how can we
exp I
mean number of other issues rela to this
type of work how start making some
decisions to make some progress on this
because it's not getting any better it's
deteriorating by the day cuz the grass
is still growing and the hes are still
growing and everything else is still gr
purely for the work that the the way
would do would would be related to the
highway so it would be clearing around
signs um there would be Cuts relating to
Vision displays and things like that um
so it would be Highway related stuff
cleaning signs um so uh uh and general
stuff uh about repairing small items I
don't think they do anything is it over
8 ft or something I mean I think there
are restrictions on what the ranges can
do and that's also one of the issues I
think um and certainly they're not
allowed as I understand it to uh you
know stick out uh cones and uh and
divert the traffic and so on so they
have to only do Works uh where it's
possible for them to park the truck in a
in a safe place and for them to work
safely on perhaps cutting back a hedge
Ro that's
overhanging a pavement or or that sort
of thing or clearing we have to do that
we we would organize them through Marcus
and Adam pres or contact somebody in
highways if if any member has uh any
particular uh area that they think
requires attention that might be in the
remit of the Rangers then by all means
uh email Marcus or you know if you want
to email me and I'll you know make sure
it gets to the right person but um you
know uh that's not a problem we do
occasionally get uh requests from I
think really Town Council has got a
request in at the moment for for several
things to be carried I mean it's where
this line stop between what we should be
doing with our present contractors what
Rangers doing addition and it's will
become a very muddy area yeah and that's
why we want it all under one umbrella
makes yeah yeah sure yeah so I mean you
B right Town C yes they have put some
forward
but our town Clark is coming up you know
she's being told well they can't do this
they can't do that I mean even a hedge
you just said by the pavement they say
they can't do that cuz it's too near the
road you know it's it's excuse after
excuse what can they do that's the whole
point of cutting back isn't it you know
make it safe for
others yeah but as you say um hopefully
we can make some progress on this very
soon cuz it's been running for so
longing on yeah yeah so put a flag up
for that one and that's why I think it
should be read really uh right Community
safety Hub um hopefully that's going
forward um
and that would be under June's remit but
uh I think we're going heav with that me
so that's
fine any any more on that one I'm up to
614 I don't know if anybody's got
anything before
that
16 17 oh sorry 16 this this business of
the uh the red on the car park Back Lane
um when's this going to
happen render it's all ret tendering
exact you know I think the original
remate was to surface part of the car
park but I think now they're going to
surface all of the car park
um because it's uh it is
deteriorating uh and that's part of the
reason why I think they've
rendered yeah res Serv the whole of the
car park yeah
um and can we have some some
clarity where the funding as I
understand a lot of the funding for this
sort of project has to come from car
parking Revenue yes is that the the case
as I understand it yes and I assume this
is in the budget and we have the revenue
available to to do this sort of big
project like this I mean
it's if I if I may chairman there
there's um we have a capital program
for car park maintenance and repair
there a capital item standing um we also
have um the off street parking cost
center as a revenue budget but there's
nothing specific in the revenue budget
it's coming under the council program
but that however is funded mainly from
the revenue
so how we got the money there is a
budget set ccle okay part works okay
that one y right thank you so we're
obviously just waiting for the tenders
on that uh
right so I'm up to
618 want to get this thing to
[Music]
work look
you right
22 and
23 23 y I've got a meeting I'm going to
the .m tomorrow evening of friends at
Cherry Orchard oh good right
um is there any more to to add to this
you know to improve phase one of the
biodiversity whole Road Improvement
involving the restoration creation of
wetland habitats in Cherry Orchard Park
do we know anything more about that I
guess that comes under my REM as well
but unfortunately Marcus has been on
holiday for the last two weeks and I'm
clutching at straws trying to find out
some I don't know details yeah would
Adam be there today I'm seeing Adam
tomorrow morning anyway so I hope you
would have some information on yeah
okay right that's the last one
there
uh next one on the agenda is the
exclusion so um pass a motion please uh
members of the public we come to the end
of business so that we can debate with
you at
present uh the remaining report contains
exempt information i' therefore asked
that we now leave the meeting uh and
it's resolved that under Section 104 of
the Local Government Act 1972 the public
excluded from the meeting for the
following item of business on the
grounds that it involves the likely
disclosure of exempt information
paragraph 3 of part one of schedule 12a
of the ACT